im universum wurden hunderttausende
bisher verborgene galaxien entdeckt
möglich macht das das lofer projekt in
europa das im langwelligen infrarot und
radiobereich sucht dabei sind 100.000
einzel antennen zu einem gigantischen
virtuellen teleskop zusammengekoppelt
das so einen durchmesser von 1900
kilometern hat aufgespürt wurden dabei
nicht nur die galaxien sondern auch
super spannende details zu schwarzen
löchern klicks um science-fiction hier
gibt es täglich faszinierendes 1 videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
konkret macht der europaweite teleskop
verbund low frequency array lofar eine
der umfangreichsten
himmelsdurchmusterungen überhaupt
möglich hier geht es um eine genaue
analyse im radiowellenbereich der bisher
wirklich wenig erforscht ist bei
radiowellen handelt es sich um die
längsten wellen des elektromagnetischen
spektrums ihre wellenlänge kann zwischen
knapp einen millimeter und mehr als
einem kilometer liegen
das ziel von lofer die erstellung einer
radio himmelskarte mit niedriger
frequenz nämlich zwischen 10 bis 80
megahertz und 110 bis 240 megahertz ein
nicht einfaches vorhaben für das eine
menge an rechenzeit und teleskop
leistung notwendig ist realisiert hat
dass lofer forschungsteam das projekt
durch die kopplung von 100.000 einzel
antennen in ganz europa und zwar mit
hilfe eines hochgeschwindigkeits
glasfasernetzes so erschufen die
fachleute eine virtuelle empfang
schüssel mit einem durchmesser von
sagenhaften 1900 kilometern also ein
europäisches netzwerk an radioteleskopen
dass alle empfangenen signale zu einem
einzigen signal kombiniert in
deutschland sind sechs messstationen zu
finden unter anderem betrieben von der
universität hamburg und der ruhr
universität bochum dazu dominik schwarz
von der universität bielefeld lofer
produziert unglaubliche datenmengen
wir müssen das äquivalent von 10
millionen dvds verarbeiten
dies stellt höchste ansprüche an soft
und hardware und ist nur durch ein
internationales und interdisziplinäres
team möglich insgesamt sind rund 200
astronomen astronomen aus 18 ländern an
dem projekt beteiligt und eine erste
auswertung der daten
dass sich der ganze aufwand gelohnt hat
denn die neu erstellte himmelskarte
enthüllt hunderttausende galaxien von
denen uns die meisten bisher unbekannt
waren
ihre radiostrahlung hat wohl milliarden
von lichtjahren zurückgelegt denn viele
der neu entdeckten galaxien liegen
extrem weit entfernt und das projekt
lofer kann einen weit größeren erfolg
verbuchen denn durch die radiostrahlung
war es erstmalig möglich kosmische
magnetfelder die sich zwischen diesen
zahlreichen galaxien befinden zu
kartieren
dabei handelt es sich um wirklich enorme
magnetische strukturen die bislang
lediglich theoretisch vermutet worden
waren
dazu der bonner forscher rainer beck
lofer liefert hinweise dass der gesamte
raum zwischen den galaxien magnetisch
sein könnte auch wenn die neue
himmelskarte bislang nur etwa zwei
prozent der geplanten beobachtungen
entspricht konnten in diesem kleinen
ausschnitt bereits jetzt knapp 300
25.700 radio quellen detektiert werden
das ist wirklich sensationell dazu das
forschungsteam die dichte der radio
quellen ist damit in dieser karte um das
zehnfache höher als bei den sensi
tiefsten bisher existierenden radio
spectrum 2 west mit großem himmels
ausschnitt doch die karte kann noch mehr
sie wirft auch ein neues licht auf die
supermassereichen schwarzen löcher die
sich im zentrum von galaxien befinden
wie genau wechselwirkt das schwarze loch
und seine würz galaxie das ist eine
wichtige frage zu der forschungsteams
weltweit tüfteln und die nun beantwortet
werden konnte
denn die aktuellen radio daten zeigen
dass sogenannte jets in jeder großen
galaxie zu finden sind sogar in unserer
milchstraße
wie erst vor kurzem bekannt wurde diese
material strahlen namens jets sind vor
allem im radiobereich sichtbar und
bestehen aus beschleunigten teilchen sie
entstehen wenn schwarze löcher materie
einsaugen die hohe empfindlichkeit von
nova enthüllte zudem dass diese schwarze
löcher ständig wachsen enthalten
schwarze löcher die weltformel um dazu
mehr zu erfahren hier draufklicken
anschauen und neugier zu harmonieren bis
dann bleibt dran